今日はちょっと寝すげにかかっちゃってすいません
今日82番からです お願いします
ではよろしくお願いします
やたぴらはどがんびろ
ヴィッパサナーアナビロ
エワンダンマニスッワナ
ヴィッパシダンティパンディタ
もう一度言います やたぴらはどがんびろ
ヴィッパサナーアナビロ
エワンダンマニスッワナ
ヴィッパシダンティパンディタ
この偈の意味も結構簡単だとは思います
やたぴらはどがんびろ
ラハダっていうのは湖のことで
ガンビーラっていうのはとても深い湖と例えていますね
ヴィッパサンノーアナビロ
水がとても澄んでいて
アナビラっていうのはいろいろ波が立ったり
泥が上がったりすることはなく
とても安定していて 深い綺麗な澄んだ水がある湖のところ
そのようにエワンダンマニスッワナ法を聞いて
パンディタ智慧のある人々はヴィッパシダンティ心は清らかになるということで心に喜びを感じると
ここで教えてかっているのは
普通我々の心はね かなり波を立っているんですね
あらゆる 竜巻やらね 渦巻きやらね
心っていうのはかなり興奮状態で
いろんなことで波を立ってるんです
そこがブッダの真理を聞いてみると
心はとても落ち着いて
深い湖の深い大きい湖のように落ち着いてしまいますよということで
で 心に波が立って何か悪いかということもありますけど
やっぱりすべて心なんですね
僕は私はよく言っていることで
体から心が抜けたらただの物体
ただの死体ね 何のこともないんですね
だからそれよくいつでも頭の中に覚えておいた方がいいんですよ
自分の肉体と机とか椅子とか建物とか
何ら変わりもないんだよと
この差が心というところなんですね
だから普通 なんで何回もこれ言いますかというと
普通私たちは考えることが心だと思ってるんですね
だからこれはずーっとそう思っていたんだから
この一回二回聞いただけで
ああそうかっていうことにはなりません
やっぱりいつでもやっぱり考えることが心やと思ってしまうんですね
しかし 考えることっていうのは
心という働きのほんの一部だけなんですよ
例えば東京都庁が日本だよと言っても
ちょっとおかしいんですね
東京都庁は日本の一部であって
日本といえばもっとでっかいんですね
もっと大きいんですね
じゃあ だったら国会議事堂が日本の政府でしょうかと
そうでもないと思いますけどね
やっぱり国民も含めて全部日本であって
日本政府であって 国であって
だから一部だけなんですね
だから一部が 例えば国会議事堂でやってることは
かなり我々に誰にでも影響ある大変なことかもしれませんだけど
だからといってそのところだけやと思っちゃうと
もうこれこっちは勘違いなんですよ
日本の総理大臣がすごいかもしれませんだけど
国民が反対したら 1 日にして全部職を辞めなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 政府の方々は国民のことをいつでも気にして気にして仕事をしているし
国民も政府のことを気にしてるしということの感じで
日本国家といえばみんな入るんですね
しかし 個人個人で日本人はもうそんなこと言ったって
私には何の関係もないんだぞとかね
私には何の力もないんだぞと思うかもしれません
ですから この心っていうことが
そういうふうな考え方で理解した方が
考えることだけ心じゃないんですね
では 心ははっきりと何なのかと理解するためには
肉体が物体だと見るんですね
肉体は完全に物質の塊で物体であると
ですが 椅子と机とビルと建物などなどとは何か違いがあるんですね
この違いがあるところは全部まとめて心と呼ぶんですね
ですから 私が言うのは心臓の鼓動やら血液の流れやらね
そういうものは物体では起こらないもので
機械で起こらせることできますけど
しかし生き物としての心臓の動き
血液の流れっていうのはかなり違いますね
ですから この我々の心っていうのは
細胞一個一個にも働いているんですね
それから一つまとめて
お互いいろんなセクションに分けて
いろいろ仕事を分割して
お互い総合的に見事に一つのファンクションとして
機能として働いているんです
その一つのファンクション機能っていうのは生きているということなんですね
だから考えることも よく見れば生きているということであって
悩んだり楽しかったりすることも生きているということであって
ご飯食べたら寝たりすることも生きているっていうことなんですね
だから生きていることが心なんですね
というわけで 生きていることが混乱しちゃって
興奮しちゃって 竜巻を起こしたりしていいのかと
それ決していいことじゃないんですね
だから それがとても澄んで清らかで落ち着いているということは
結構幸福な生き方にはなるんですね
だから肉体はいくらいじっても人は幸福になりません
やっぱり心ですよ 楽しいと思うのを心
悲しいと思うのを心で
もう何でも心なんですね
例えば自分の体が弱いとかね
体があの形があんまりカッコ悪いとかね
それは物体はそんなことは思わないんですね
やっぱり心なんですね
そこでもう人が自分の体に対して別に何も思わなくても
本人がやっぱり自分の体は良くないとか
いろいろコンプレックス持ったりする可能性もあります
だからそこを客観的な事実と関係なく
例えば我々の目から見れば
もう結構痩せている女性の女の子たちも
やっぱりもう痩せなくて
痩せなくてとね 必死なんですね
何回もそういう女の子に言った
あんた何考えてるのかと
もう痩せすぎやと そんなこと言われても
ここら辺 ここら辺はまだ肉がついていてとかね
まあこれは話にならないなと思って
それで話をやめるんですけど
やめたんですけど やっぱり客観的な事実と関係なく
その人の心がそういう気持ちを持ったりする
それによって生き方が変わったりもする
ですから 痩せたいというのも心であって
もっと背が伸びてほしいと思うのも心であって
だから仏教 の過程についても
心がいろいろ考えたり
意地悪にしようとたりしたりはするんですね
だから心というのはイコール命で
心って仏教でいう言葉はもう生きているということの話なんですね
だから心は清らかにするしかないんですね
そこは異論は立ちません
命そのものが汚れて混乱して
それでいいやと それは冗談ですよ
だからこの仏教以外の世界ではね
まあ欲なんかは別にこれは普通だよとか
怒りなんかは普通だよとかね
まあ人間にはもう まあ喜怒哀楽は
まあそれはとても美しいことで
普通にそんなことこのあまり勉強していないんだから言うんであって
だいたい世の中ではね
まあ仏教以外はみんなこの霊魂魂あると思ってるんですね
だから霊魂は関係ないんだと
こう感情的に まあ心だけでは喜怒哀楽があって
それが楽しいんじゃないかと
死んだらどうしても永遠の天国に行くんだぞという気持ちを持ってる方々は
まあそうやって心の汚れを認めるんですね
あってほしいことやと
仏教はもうかなり大変なことを言ってるんだと
もうもう致命的な間違いを犯しているんだとか
偉そうなことを言ったりはするんですね
言ってる人々は致命的な間違いを引き起こしたりして
まあもう世界に嫌われているんですけど
で 神と魂を信じることが正しいと
もう証拠はないしね だからこの心といえば生きるということで
命ということで それが強く清らかで汚れがなくっていうことが当然な考えなんですね
だから それを知っている人がブッダの話を聞いて
やっぱり心落ち着いて穏やかにならなくちゃいけないんだぞと思いますね
そこでブッダの話っていうのは
基本的にはね 一切の物事は無常であるということ
すべて無常であるならば
そんなに激しく感情的にならなくてもいいんですよ
冷静でいればいいんです
物事は変わるんです 変わらないものはないんです
それは見れば見るほど変わり方が明確に見えるんですね
大雑把でいい加減に見ると
もうもうそんなにはっきりは見えませんだけど
どう見たっても世界は変わるっていうことは見えるはずなんです
自分も変わるっていうことは見えるはずなんです
だから もっともっと真剣に見てみると
もうかなり激しく物事は変わっていくっていうことは見えてくる
それでなおさら知恵を成長させてみると
瞬間瞬間物事は変わるんだっていうことは見えるんですね
だから 変わるものに対して
そんなに感情的になってする意味がないんですね
これ自体が無知であると
で そこでこの変わるものには執着しないんですね
で 執着がかなり問題を起こすんですね
私たちはあれも欲しい
これも欲しいとものに執着するんですが
執着する主体自分も変わっちゃうし
執着する対象も変わっていくんですね
だから執着は初めからもう不可能なんですね
成り立たない だから不可能なことをやってるんだから
かなり苦しみに陥っちゃうんですね
どうしてもこの不可能なことをやりたいんですね
だからそれが無知というんですね
まあ例えば普通の人が
自分がどうしても空気に浮いてみたいんだと
このままでいろいろ道具とかあれやこれやとか使わないで
ヘリウム入ってる風船にも入らないで
ただ浮いてみたいと これ不可能なんですね
それでも諦めないならば
その人でどれほどひどい目に遭うのかっていうことはもう切りがないんですよ
あるいは何も道具なく水の中で生活したいとかね
それもまだ人間にとって不可能なことなんですね
それでも不可能のことに挑戦しちゃうと
その人は苦しみになっちゃうんですね
例えば大きい石でもね
体に繋いでもらって もう水の中に飛び込むと
私は水の中に生活すると
どうなるんでしょうかという
すぐ人生が終わってしまうんですね
だから我々は完全にそういう人にはとてももうイカれてるんだ
頭がおかしいと 無知だと
愚者やと言うでしょうに
同じことなんですよ 執着っていうのは不可能なんですね
不可能ですが 執着するんです
だから必ずしも人間が苦しみに陥るようになっているんです
仏教は別に悲観主義を語っているわけじゃないんです
仏教は関係ないんだと
あなた方のことはそういう態度なんです
あなた方はもう執着 不可能な無常たる現象に執着して
もう馬鹿まで苦しんでいるだけではないかと
だから人間やることは何であろうとも執着する目的でやっているんですね
だから何やっても苦しみが出てくるんです
しかし 話を聞いてみたら
これやったら幸福になる
あれやったら幸福になる
楽しみになると言ってはいるんです
金儲けたら幸福になるとかね
子供はちゃんと教育受けてもらえばそれこそ幸福になるとかね
そういういろんなことをね
あれがあれば これがあれば幸福になります
楽しくなりますということで
いろんなものを集めたりはしますが
それ執着なんですね 結局は
幸福にならないんですね
かえってかなり苦しいことになるんですね
では 苦しいことがあっても
自分の目的にどうしても達しますよということで
そこはなかったことにするんですね
そんなこと言っていられると
目的に達しませんよと
やっぱりものは試しだと思って
水の中に飛び込んでみるんですね
人の話を聞いて やっぱり死ぬかもしれませんよと
そんなこと初めからこうやって自分の希望に達しませんよと思って
石を体につけちゃって
水に飛び込んでみるんですね
それで苦しいことになってしまいます
だから このお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
一切はもう無常であって固定してないんですね
何でも支えられてあるんですね
この支えられてあるんだから
あるとは言えないんです
言葉では例えば今蛍光灯の光があると言っても
支えられて光があるんであって
だからあるということはもう言語上使うしかないんだけど
文字通りの意味ではありませんね
あると言えないんですよ
支えられてある それで支えがなくなったらないっていうことで
そこはお釈迦様がおっしゃっている因果法則なんですね
蛍光灯に光があるといえば
まああるんですよとは言いますよ
世間常識では まああるでしょうと
だからといって光という固定した何かあるわけじゃないんです
固定してないんです ずっと消えていくんだからこそ光なんです
そこでずっと電気が流れて支えているんだから光なんですね
だから じゃあこの光に執着しようと言っても
これがもう成り立たないんですね
だからそこら辺は まあよく考えて理解すると
心がすごい楽になるんですね
だから私はこの蛍光灯のこの光は好きですよと
一般的に普通に言ってもいいんだけど
大体誰はそういうことでは困りません
だから まあこれはスイッチ切れたらもう切れるとも知ってるし
もう蛍光灯光は好きですが
蛍光灯も死んでしまっちゃうしね
時間経つと だからそこは知ってますけど
やっぱりそれでもやっぱり同じメーカーの同じ機械の同じものでなければとか
また苦しくてまた探したりするんですね
だからこの 例えば日本ではね
ちょっとした屋台ラーメン屋さんにしてもかなり苦しいんですよ
仕事は 幼稚園見て一番楽しい仕事って幼稚園だと思いますけど
何もやることないのに
もう地獄にいるような苦しいんですね
この面倒見る人々は まあ随分シンプルなのに
もう屋台ラーメン屋さんもかなり苦労しているんですね
これはお金が入らないんだからという苦労じゃないんですよ
この無常に逆らっているんですね
だから何かを決まってる味を発見して
だからまるっきり同じ味のものを再現しなくちゃいけないんですよ
これは大変苦しいと思いますよ
普通 寿司握るってことは誰にでもできた方がいいんじゃないかなと
日本の一般伝統的な食べ物でしょうに
随分自慢しているでしょうに
日本と言えば 日本料理でも寿司第一でしょうとかね
外国でもそう思っているんですけど
しかし 寿司を握れる人はほとんどいないんですね
日本の代表的な食べ物だったら
もうもう大体高校生でもはい
作りますよと これは我々の伝統的な食べ物だと
いう風にならなくちゃいかないんでしょうに
しかし 寿司を握るためには何年も苦労しなくちゃいけないし
それで何が苦労するかと
この握り方 形 この圧力は米の間の圧力を中に入れる
そういうものを必ず同じものにならなくちゃということで
激しく苦しく修行するんですよ
だから そういうことを見てみてください
この あの同じものを再現するということは不可能なんです
これ 不可能に挑戦するんだから
もうどう見ても一番簡単ですから
寿司っていうのはね 別にもう何も考える必要ないし
ただ米とアレと合わせれば
それだけの生の魚ともうちょこっとワサビも入れてね
それだけのことなんですけど
味噌汁の方がもっと難しいかもしれませんしね
まあそれぞれのも出汁の使い方もいろいろあるし
だからこの私たちはこの同じものを再現しようという
このとてつもない愚かなことに挑戦するんですよ
だからもう何年も免許取らなきゃできないということになっていて
だからそれもかえって錯覚なんですよ
だって毎回毎回魚違うでしょうに
で 米も違うでしょうに
体も変わっていくでしょうに
そこはいかにごまかすのかという
これは女性がいつだって若々しくて
年の年代でいたいと思うことと同じことなんです
結構苦しくなるんですね
だから無常ということを覚えておけば
いかに楽かと これも別に覚えなくても信じなくても事実ですからね
だから世の中のあらゆる現象があるんだけど
全て支えられて一時的にあるだけですと
だから種も引掛けも何もないんだと
何にも 固定したものは何もないんだということが分かった時点で
もう悟りに達していますよ
悟りということは そこはもう分かったということなんです
それからもう心はもうまた悩みは作らないんです
もう想像を絶する自由が味わうんですよ
気楽を味わうんですよ
安らぎ味わうんですね
だから私が安らぎを 安らぎを感じているんだっていうことさえないんですね
私は安らぎ感じているんだっていうことも
私という存在感だからね
それさえも消えるんだから
もうもうもう人間の言葉を超えているんですね
だからブッダの話を聞くと
もう当然当たり前 理性のある人なら愚か者はもう話になりませんからね
理性のある人なら大変喜びを感じるはずなんですね
説法を聞いただけでも
心の粗波が全部なくなるはずなんです
だから心の怒りであろうが
嫉妬であろうかね 欲であろうか
落ち込むであろうか 傲慢であろうか
全てこの無常ではないという前提で成り立つんです
だから随分もう話はシンプルですけど
煩悩は生まれませんよ
私たちのあらゆる希望があって
願望があってね またもう千五百の煩悩もあって
もうキリがないでしょうね
全てただものは無常で永いんだよという
もう極限の無知から生まれるんですね
だから生きるという努力は
結局は無常に逆らうという努力でしょうし
無常に逆らえませんだから生きることは苦になっちゃうし
で まあそんな風になってしまいますね
だからお釈迦様の教えというのは
全ての現象は無常であること
苦であること 実体のないものであると
それからその現象というのは因果法則によって現れるんだから
もう消えるのは当たり前の当然なことで
初めからもう執着は不可能なものであったということで
執着は消えるんですね
普通は執着は捨てなさいと言うと
何か損するんじゃないかなという錯覚が起こるんですね
で 何も損しませんね 初めからも得をしていたわけじゃないんです
だから こんなこと言ったって
もうね 執着すると何か損するんだと
なんかそう思っちゃいますね
では今得しているんでしょうかと
欲で 感情で 怒りで 執着で何か得をしているのかというと
何も得がないんですよ
損ばっかりなんですけど
だから損が消えるんですね
執着なくなったら だから執着をなくすっていうことが
何か損することじゃなくて得することなんです
例えば病気がなくなったら損しますかと
と言うならばね やっぱり損する
どういう損でしょうかと
病気でいた時はみんなちゃんと面倒見てくれたんだとかね
自分のベッドのところにお医者さんも看護婦さんもよく何回も来てきたんだと
ベッドのところに食べ物を持ってきたんだと
食べたらみんな片付けてくれたんだと
すごい楽でしたと だから病気が治って大損やと言いますかね
だから執着なくすことは損じゃないんです
そこは損やと思うことは
病気の人は病気が治って本当に損しましたということと同じ話なんです
本当は病気でいることが損なんですね
誰もタダでやってくれませんからね
そういうものは 病院に 1 日いることと
ホテルで 1 日いることとは違いますからね
ですから この執着をなくすこと自体が損がなくなるということなんですね
そういうことで この ブッダの話を聞くと
心は清らかになるというね
それもヴィッパシーダンティパンディタ
愚か者はもう理解はしないんですよ
どうしても自分でもの事を考えて理解する能力は人間には期待するんです
要求するんです お釈迦様が
理性のある人間になりなさいと
理性があるならば これから話を話してあげますよと
私は今までの信仰は捨てませんよとかね
今までの考え方は捨てませんよと言ったら
もうその話にはなりません
捨てなさいとお釈迦様は言いませんし
理性だけ持ちなさいと
それからもう真理を発見していきなさいと
初めからもう断るということになってくると
もうかなりもうもう門が閉ざしてしまいますね
短いエピソードありますけど
どうしますかね 私はこの物語を喋るのはあまり上手じゃないんだからね
えーと はい 次の偈に行きます
エピソードも面白いと思いますけど
読んでください よいしょ